it's agony for natalya built plum in
surrey on the phone to her mother nadja
in ukraine and struggling to get her out
of the country
natalia's mother who has difficulty
walking took this video at a uk visa
center in the western city of levive on
monday
filming as an official told people it
was closing and the equipment needed to
take people's biometric identity had
been removed
if i don't bring it here i'm going to
lose her
i'm sorry what's your message to the
british government please help to bring
our relatives here and keep them safe do
you think the process is putting people
off from trying to leave ukraine
this process can be much easier
this everything can be done much easier
and quicker a lot of people waiting
applications for ukrainians to join
their families in the uk now have to be
made at around half a dozen visa centres
like this one across europe but some say
they've been told the process will take
weeks
when people call the helpline they say
you don't need an appointment and just
to turn up this is the voice of british
man matt palmer filming in the polish
capital warsaw on monday after flying
out to help his ukrainian sister-in-law
the crowd is told by officials they only
have five staff and anyone without
appointments should leave we'd already
prepared the forms for a visitor visa
but it still took me several hours to go
through the forms and get them submitted
and i'm a british english-speaking you
know graduate with good english skills
not somebody who's fleeing a war zone
with nothing more than a smartphone
in jezo near the polish border with
ukraine at another site designated as a
visa application point people queuing in
freezing temperatures complained of a
lack of information and staff to help
them
in calais where dozens of ukrainians had
arrived hoping to get visas people have
been told to travel nearly a hundred
miles to a pop-up center in the city of
lille
the home office says it's increased
capacity to process applications as
quickly as possible and its offices in
warsaw and jezzo are adequately staffed
lisa holland sky news